Hi, I'm Beardyman.
Where were you with the
"and I'm Tom Scott"? Jesus.
I'm just getting some breath!
This chemistry, honestly(!)
I'm with Beardyman, who...
Are you just staring stone in the camera there?
I'm staring dead-eye into that camera.
[indistinct]
No, I was rolling with that.
I demand an epic crash zoom.
(chuckles)
Let's finger-point.
(both snap fingers)
I'm with Beardyman,
who... makes... noises?
I don't know how to describe you.
Ten years ago,
I'd have called you a beatboxer,
but there's a lot more
equipment here these days.
Ever since I started it, I've been
more interested in using technology
to morph my voice into...
whatever else I want it to be.
And so, now you're gonna
do that to my voice.
Oh yeah. Get ready.
You're gonna be a mega-star.
That's Tom Scott.
Hello!
I'm Beardyman.
What's going on?
Hello, Tom.
Yo, yo.
What kind of music
do you like, Tom?
My music tastes are really basic.
Like, regardless of the genre,
if you put "pop" in front of it,
I'm probably gonna be okay.
So, like, just basic as hell.
What about if you put "pop"
on the end of it, like "synthpop"?
Yeah. Yeah, that'll do.
Or "post-pop"?
Sure.
Okay. "Pop" on the beginning is...
That is just pop made out of
the Postman Pat theme tune.
(chuckles)
My goal for this was, like, banger.
That's what I'm going for.
Do you know about hyperpop?
Okay well, Charli XCX is part of
the whole PC Music collective.
She makes bangers,
and they're hyperpop-infused.
Caroline Polachek also makes—
Yeah, let's aim for that.
Do you know about Caroline Polachek?
(laughs) Let's aim for
two guys in a basement doing that.
Yeah okay, fine.
Yeah!
Okay, this is a good musical steer.
Alright.
Difficult to pull off! (laughs)
Well let's— let's—
Let's do it.
Let's go for somewhere around pop.
No, 'cause— Look, 'cause like...
Your— Your singing voice...
is... no doubt sublime.
So let me see if
there's a bit of autotune.
(with faint vocoding)
I'll just talk— Oh okay, right.
So, I just need to give you a
♫ No-oo-oo-oo-oo-
(in chords)
oo-oo-oo-
(with chorus and reverb)
woow-ohh-ooo ♫
(with reverb, in unison) Nice.
There you are, man.
Yeah, okay.
(reverb off) So yeah.
So we can totally do hyperpop.
'Cause it takes from K-pop,
which is dazzling and intense,
and it's just a lot, and...
But there's a kind of squeaky-clean
commercialism to it.
Yes. This is great.
Yeah, let's do it. Okay.
So right, I'm— instinctively,
I was just going to the mic.
But I'm not, right now.
Hooh, okay. Alright.
This is on me. This is on me.
So I'll tell you what we need.
Can you just put it really close?
Give me like a...
Just say the letter B as hard as you can.
Like, buh.[/bə/]
Mhm. But that's...
(hammers /bə/ sample)
Okay, harder than that.
Bit like, (spits hard)
Yeah, okay.
/bf/! No, that was bad.
No, that was good.
(hammers /bf/ sample)
No, that's an F in that.
Let me give that one more time.
Take out the fricatives.
/b/!
(hammers /b/ sample)
That's a legit kick drum there.
I tried to keep the aspiration back.
(hammers /b/ sample as kick)
Okay, so...
Now I need something with a...
a plosive with a fricative,
please sir.
(gently) /pf/
(hammers /pf/ sample as snare)
That's great.
Now, could you give me—
Could you, like...
give me some sort of bongo-like sound
by just going like ogh.[/ɔʔ/]
/ɔʔ/, something like that.
(gags faintly)
No, you're being garroted.
Too far in the back of my throat.
Can you try, like, cluck like a chicken?
Give me, like, linguistics terms.
I did linguistics. I can give you a...
I actually didn't do linguistics.
But I can say, "cluck like a chicken",
and that's...
In linguistics terms, what would you call
a (clucks), like a "buck"?
Like a cockerel?
I honestly don't know.
Alright, but I know what you're looking for.
I thought you did linguistics, man(!)
Back of the throat, explosion out.
Yeah, sure.
/pʷh/
(hammers /pʷh/ sample)
(hammers samples as percussion)
That's good. I think I wanna layer that.
This is good for:
(performs percussion, hammers kick sample)
I'll pitch that down.
(kick samples at lower pitch)
(performs kick beat)
(melodic kick flourish)
(kick beat playback)
(adds high harmonic kick beat)
(adds low harmonic kick beat)
That's magic. I've got no other word for it.
(adds snare beat)
(modifies snare reverb)
(adds white noise to snare)
Alright. Now, can you give
a "tiss"? /ts/, /ts/.
(sustained) /ts/
(/ts/ samples as open hi-hat)
Yep, and a few more.
Just variate the formant a little bit.
Tsu.[/tsɸ/]
Yeah.
(shorter) /ts/, /ts/
(performs dynamic hi-hat beat)
(hi-hats accelerate)
(adds reverb to hi-hat)
(adds buzzy modifier to hi-hat)
(glitchy hi-hat fill)
(beat stops)
That's legit.
(laughs uproariously)
Wait, so how—
That's incredible!
Don't laugh, man. This is no joke.
You're gonna be a huge star.
That's— That—
You're gonna be supporting
Caroline Polachek on tour.
(chuckles)
I've already DM'd her on Twitter.
It's happening. Right, listen.
I don't— I don't have words!
I love it when I just get to stand back
and watch someone do... just...
I don't have words, okay?!
That's amazing!
Where we're going...
we don't need words.
Check it, check it, check it.
Let's go.
(beat plays)
(beat stops)
I think we actually need— Can you give me...
another really savage plosive?
Like a— going (spits)
Just give a few varieties of plosive,
with as little...
Aspiration.
As little aspiration as possible, yeah.
/pəʔ/
Mhm.
And no vocalisation at all.
/k/
Oh, that was good.
Give me that again.
/k/
Right. I can use that.
That's not what I wanted, but...
Okay.
(beat plays)
(adds /k/ as clap sample)
Right, now some Ps.
Ps and Bs.
So, unaspirated—
But like—
This might not be something
you've ever done before.
I've gotta try and be loud
without aspirating.
When you're doing a kick drum,
and you're beatboxing a kick drum,
if there's any kind of fuzz or fizz
or aspiration at all,
it ruins the effect, so it's more
tensing your lips as much as possible.
(spits)
It takes practice, but...
(repeats /p/ gradually softer)
Okay, I think I got one.
(hammers /p/ sample)
That's actually pretty good.
(beat plays)
(performs sample as kick thickener)
(beat stops)
Can you give me some more /ts/?
(sustained) /ts/
(beat plays)
/ts/
(performs samples as secondary hi-hats)
(hi-hat glitch-trill)
(adds phasing effect)
(brief ping-pong effect)
(brief zapping effect)
Wait, how are you making that?
(beat stops)
Oh, so you wanna know how that was done?
Yeah!
So, I've called it "zap" on here.
(isolated ping-pong and zap effects)
This is a VST plugin called Turnado.
And when you turn up
the "zap" thing...
(effect increases)
it's turning up this thing.
Those are some words
I vaguely recognise!
It's like a tempo-synchronised
low-frequency oscillator
which is sweeping a
resonant filter.
That's what that's doing.
(beat stops)
It gives you the impression of a laser zap noise.
Yeah.
But...
all it's doing is applying effects
to the /ts/s that you put in.
But also on the way, I was
quantising it live with the tempo.
So no matter what you do,
it's always gonna be deadlocked in time.
Let's keep going.
Great, let's—
(both laugh)
Right.
We will need a sort of hoover synth.
What do you want?
What vowel do you want?
Interpolate through
a bunch of different vowels.
I can do that. That's a standard sweep
through IPA vowel chart. I can do that.
♪ Absolutely ♪
Right, we're gonna start with...
♪ /i:~e:~ɑ:~o:~u/ ♪
That got away from me
at the end there.
I love that so much.
I would listen to that all day.
(chuckles)
So...
(vocoded playback)
It's all very forward.
(taps sample key testingly)
Can I try something that's more—
No, that's perfect.
Okay! I was gonna sweep the back there,
but never mind.
No, it's all good.
(holds resonant note)
(sweeps resonance)
(beat starts, performs melody)
(hammers chords)
(performs sloppy melody)
(holds chords, adds effects)
(performs melodic riff)
(riff loops in playback)
(adds overdub flourish)
(performs high overdub flourishes)
(performs synth bass over beat)
(synth bass loops in playback)
I was gonna ask if you wanted
something else for the bass,
but you kinda got it!
Yeah!
(adds overdub flourishes)
Right, we need some lyrics.
Wow!
We need some lyrics. Come on.
I'm amazed.
I'm absolutely amazed.
You need the Tom Scott sample.
You need the trademark Tom Scott sample.
"I'm here at the government..."
(laughs)    Eh...
"...music outside Kettering."
With a serious look and...
hand-based gestures
that suggest the importance.
Yeah, left that behind a while ago.
Yeah no, 'cause
the old Tom Scott is gone.
Now, there is Hyperpop Scott.
That should be your new—
Hyper-Scott.
This is Hyper-Scott.
There we go, there we go.
No, that's getting
very close to "Great Scott" there.
That's getting very close to
Back to the Future.
(chuckles slowly)
Well, give us some lyrics, guys.
It's all very good.
I mean, give us a topic first.
Yeah.
Like, what do you write
a hyperpop song about?
Quantum entanglement?
Quantum entanglement.
I'm not a physicist!
Bridge in Leeds.
(Tom and Beardyman laugh)
Um...
A gazebo.
Yo, d'y'know what?
Actually no, 'cause like...
I like the idea of a gazebo,
because hyperpop is all about...
taking pop tropes, and...
doing them to the
point of absurdity.
And there was
the "Umbrella" song by Rihanna.
Why not do one about
a gazebo?
"You're under my gazebo."
"Shelter me from the rain." That kinda stuff.
Sure, sure.
Only one person in here
is a good improviser.
And it ain't me, it ain't me.
Okay. Well, that's a start.
Like, "I'm under your gazebo."
Something like that.
And you can just say the words.
I'll play the melodies.
Yeah, okay, yeah.
"Shelter me from the rain."
What else, what else?
Oh, that's good. That's good.
Yeah.
We should be writing these down somewhere.
"When it's raining, I—"
Do you wanna take the notes?
Take some notes.
"Keep me in your shade."
(laughs)
So far we've got, "Shelter me from the rain.
Keep me in your shade."
Which actually doesn't sound like
a great... metaphor?
Yeah, it's kind of clumsy, but like...
It's more— I think the shade thing is like...
The shade's what you don't want.
Every time my brain locks onto a thing,
"Oh I could say that—"
No, we are three conversations
further down the line!
...Is that a lyric?
Actually, that's a good lyric.
"Three conversations
further down the line." That'll do.
That's good. It's quite enigmatic.
Not sure what it means. Great, stick it in.
If it makes you go, "Wait, what?"
then it's a good lyric.
Yep.
(giggles deeply)
We've got a first verse here.
Do you wanna just—
(snort)
Shall I just sing some things,
and you just riff around?
Yeah-yeah-yeah. So.
(backing track plays)
(lightly vocoded) Do I speak? Do I sing?
How do you want it?
(music stops)
I think—
Put it really close to your mouth and
shout as loud as you can, and that'll do it.
Yeah.
Okay.
(backing track plays)
(slowly, lightly vocoded)
♪ Shelter me from the rain ♪
Yeah, can you hear it?
I mean, it sounds really bad to me.
Try again.
It might sound better now.
♪ Shelter me from the rain
Keep me in your shade ♪
♪ Three conversations
further down the line ♪
I hate everything about that!
(music stops, vocoding off)
I hate how I sang that.
I can't...
I will be trying to hit a key,
but I don't know what key I need to hit.
Yeah, it's confusing.
What might help is if you sing quieter
but cup the mic and hold it to your mouth.
Like that? Okay.
So that there's just more volume.
Yeah, I'll give you a bit of...
(heavy vocoding and reverb)
One-two, one-two. Okay, that is...
That is very weird and uncomfortable,
but we'll go with it.
Keep talking.
One-two, one-two, one-two.
(added echo and harmoniser)
One-two. Oh! Okay, that's...
Wow!
(vocoding intensifies)
I'll just keep talking. That is...
That's speech jamming.
That's amazing!
Okay, uh. I guess
I'll sing some things,
if you... you try that.
(backing track without percussion)
♪ Shelter me from the rain
Keep me in your shade ♪
(scoffs)
(isolated, looped) ♪ Shelter me from the rain
Keep me in your shade ♪
So those are not the notes I sang...
but it sounds... way nicer
than what I sang.
That's—That's beautiful.
♪ Shelter me from the rain ♪
Can you just sing "Ooo"?
♪ Keep me in your shade ♪
♪ Ooooooo- ♪
♪ Shelter me from the rain ♪
(vocoding brightens)
♪ -oooooo ♪
♪ Keep me in your shade ♪
♪ Shelter me from the rain ♪
♪ Ooooooo ♪
♪ Keep me in your shade ♪
(lead synth fades in)
♪ Shelter me from the rain ♪
♪ Keep me in your shade ♪
(bass synth resumes)
♪ Shelter me from the rain ♪
(both laugh triumphantly)
♪ Keep me in your shade ♪
(percussion fades in)
♪ Shelter me from the rain ♪
♪ Keep me in your shade ♪
(percussion briefly drops out)
Okay, let me—
Let me give you another lyric.
♪ Three conversations
further down the line ♪
That's great. Okay.
(music stops)
This is good. So there's our chorus.
"Shelter me from the rain,
keep me in your shade."
So wait. "Shelter me from the rain,
Alright, so it's "further conversations",
something like that.
It's [bleep]ing great.
Something like that.
Yeah, so there's stuff
about conversation. This is good!
Something about, like...
Contact?
Talking cross purposes, and...
Oh, that's nice.
You know, yeah.
Oh, I like that in the chat.
Oh my god, you're so on.
"Cross the wires of my broken umbrella".
That'll do! That's going in.
(laughs)
That's going in.
Write it down, write it down.
I'll write it down.
(wheezes)
I'm gonna change that to "crossing".
I'm gonna change it to present tense.
'Cause the rest of the song is as well.
Oh hell yeah.
Alright, we're nearly there.
We need one more thing.
So, we've got, "Let me in your shelter,
crossing the wires, lost connections".
We need, like, a fourth one on there.
Contact in something.
Oh, someone said "imperfections".
Oh, I like that. Like,
"I don't care about your imperfections".
Something like that, or...
"fixated in your imperfections."
"Feed—" I'm gonna take
two words off there.
"Feedback" and "imperfections",
and just put a comma between them.
Beautiful. That's poetry.
Yep. Yep.
Don't make sense.
Doesn't have to.
It mustn't.
(both chuckle)
So "feedback, imperfections"...
and now we need a...
generic statement.
"You're the existence
I've been looking for."
(softly) I dunno, that's a bit heavy.
Oh no, I like that.
Oh, fine!
It means nothing.
Put it in, sing it!
We're on the last verse.
We're fine.
(giggles)
"You're the existence
I've been looking for."
That is the first—
Actually, that's amazing.
It's like manifesting...
like an AI coming to life.
We've got a specific request
here, folks.
We need a thing that fits into the words
"desires" and "transmissions".
We just need a fourth item for that,
that sounds better—
Signal.
Signal?
Bit too close to "transmissions",
I think.
"Better in your shade."
The— The—
The heat.
Shielded from the...
How about
"I sound better in your shade"?
What...?
"I sound better".
"I sound better."
"...in your shade."
Whatever you want. Okay.
Yeah, I'm good with that.
Go with it, go with it.
Alright, so.
(music starts without percussion)
♪ Shelter me from the rain ♪
(synth flourish with loud echo)
♪ Let me in your shelter ♪
♪ I got a message
but couldn't tell her ♪
♪ The words do sound better
in your shade ♪
Okay, one more time.
One more time.
♪ Let me in your shelter ♪
♪ I got a message
but couldn't tell her ♪
♪ The words do sound better
in your shade ♪
(percussion fades in)
♪ Crossing the wires ♪
♪ In a broken world full of liars ♪
♪ Desires do sound better
in your shade ♪
♪ Shelter me from the rain ♪
♪ Keep me in your shade ♪
♪ From the rain ♪
(music drops out briefly)
♪ Lost connections ♪
♪ Across the decaying orbits of time ♪
♪ Transmissions sound better
in your shade ♪
♪ Feedback, imperfections ♪
♪ You're the existence
I've been looking for ♪
♪ I sound better in your shade ♪
(music ducks beneath heavy echo)
♪ Shelter me from the rain ♪
♪ Keep me in your shade ♪
(some instruments emerge)
♪ Shelter me from the rain ♪
(backing track stops, heavy vocal echo)
♪ Keep me in your shade ♪
(backing track resumes)
♪ Shelter me ♪
(hammers melodic pad stabs)
(backing track stops)
♪ Shelter me from the rain, keep me ♪
(backing track resumes)
♪ in your shade ♪
♪ Shelter me from the rain ♪
♪ Keep me in your shade ♪
(isolated percussion, glitchy vocal effect)
♪ Shelter me from the rain ♪
(isolated vocal with heavy echo)
♪ Keep me in your shade ♪
(interlude, led by sustained synth pad)
(hammers organ-like stabs)
(song ends)
(both laugh)
We got it!
It was beautiful.
Plug the tour.
(with vocoding)
♪ If you want to see me live ♪
♪ You can come on my tour ♪
♪ Where I'll be doing stuff
just like this ♪
♪ But without Tom Scott ♪
♪ Without Tom Scott ♪
♪ Oh no, the most vital part
of the equation will be missing ♪
♪ He'll be in the gazebo
of his own love ♪
♪ Nothing about me in this
has been vital ♪
♪ Actually, this has been
the most beautiful ♪
♪ synthesis of musical inclinations ♪
♪ [bleep] yeah ♪
(laughs hysterically)
Yeah. It's so cool.
[Caption+ by JS*
caption.plus | @caption_plus]
Um...
I think we got an outro there.
I think we're good.